there's so much narcissism around and
that it's not until you have really
experienced it that you
know what to look for or know the
repercussions of it even so your point
is that a lot of people don't understand
it until it happens to them
that's really the struggle because
believe it or not even in this modern
world there's some people out there
where it hasn't happened to them or
they're so good at justifying it that
they don't want to see it right and so
when a person who's going through it
actually turns to maybe a friend who
doesn't get it they'll often get
pushback and people say oh you know
that's just how they are they're just
intense and
this is not about intense this is about
something so abusive that cuts you to
the core it's an entirely different
experience and once people understand it
the only thing i've ever wanted for
people is to not blame themselves
because that's what people do in these
relationships they blame themselves and
say maybe i'm not trying hard enough and
maybe i'm not this enough and maybe i'm
not that enough so you're doing your
part
you're being abused you decide how you
want to proceed i had a
very
uh
painful pattern of being drawn to
really big personality people who are
really fun and edgy and just like wow
like a shiny object
and then you know when you're having fun
with this kind of person and you're
laughing all the time and they're really
edgy and they start to realize oh my god
they're actually kind of mean to people
or they're they lie or they do this
now all of a sudden i get scared
because i don't know how to back away
the kinds of people we sort of idolize
in our society really are often the
noisy bullies and we idolize people with
a lot of money and narcissistic people
always have more money and so if you say
i want to be a billionaire in today's
day and age and more often not saying i
want to be a pharmacist so it's the
people we value we don't value a teacher
who knocks herself out to help kids who
are in trouble learning that's not our
hero our hero is the person who has the
jets and the rockets and all this
nonsense so part of it is what we value
in our society i mean i've been duped in
my life with people and i'm like man i
feel like i'm usually a pretty good
judge of character and i can feel their
energy or get their pick up maybe more
cues than other people but i've been
there before
so i've been there too i've been taken
i've been taken this is why i started
this research this was the height of my
awkward stage
where um i really trusted someone i
thought again i thought it was a pretty
good judge of character i had felt good
vibes and good energy
however
there were red flags that i ignored
i had little hints about this person
that i was like uh you know that feeling
yeah kind of like oh well or oh yeah oh
what i'm sure that was fine yeah he was
having a bad day
so what is a narcissist and then what
are the types of narcissists so
narcissistic or narcissism or
narcissistic personalities are
characterized by inconsistent or
generally absent empathy
entitlement grandiosity arrogance
superficiality egocentricity being very
selfish chronically seeking validation
and admiration a need for a lot of
control over a situation a
hypersensitivity to criticism difficulty
regulating emotion especially when
they're frustrated or disappointed real
challenges with intimacy in a close
relationship they they're not their
their ability to have sort of the back
and forth of a relationship is
constrained by their need for
um for their own needs to be met so in
other words they almost view other
people as conveniences to meet their
needs i can go all the way back
to
friends in elementary school to
a babysitter that i once hired to
business uh associates back in the day
to like just there they are there they
are there they are there they are there
they are and it wasn't until i had a
massive issue happened with one of them
super painful
that made me go holy [ __ ]
this is a pattern
this person has been showing up in your
life since you were nine years old
and you have not learned it and now
you have a very expensive and a very
messy and a very
awful situation to clean up with
somebody that you couldn't draw
boundaries with traditionally most of us
think of the grandiose what you're
calling the overt narcissist and
grandiose narcissism is what is sort of
the the sort of
big
extroverted attention seeking look at me
i'm so great i'm at the center of the
party i'm the coolest i'm the best you
know constantly looking for the social
media followers and likes and that's
that's that person
another form of narcissism and a lot of
researchers believe that overt or
grandiose narcissism and covert
narcissism aren't necessarily always two
separate people but they're two faces of
the same coin
covert narcissism is also called
vulnerable narcissism and it's
characterized by all the stuff i talked
about but the way it shows is in a much
more passive aggressive victimized way
so instead of just being in your face
you know you're so stupid it's more like
oh god everything comes so easy to you
someone like me who actually does the
work nothing happens for me but you just
show up and you get money like ah must
be so nice to live in your little world
and so i'm like i think i was just
insulted but i think at the same time i
also feel sorry for you so i'm not sure
what to feel right now and they're
masterful at that maybe not
intentionally so when people are with
covert narcissistic people
they're actually exhausted by the
passive aggression they wonder why they
ruin every party they're brought to but
they also feel sorry for them and they
often think of the covert narcissist as
being anxious or depressed more than
they think of them as being narcissistic
because they're not the life of the
party quite the opposite they're kind of
the sad hang dog person in the corner of
the party who's angry at everybody and
always looks like they're on the verge
of getting into a bar fight that's your
covert narcissist as time went on i kept
ignoring the red flags i kept ignoring
the red flags
and of course i ended up it ended up
that he was completely lying to me that
um so many of the things he had told me
were completely false or had a tiny
kernel of truth
and i gave him a couple of months of
very
what i what i gave him my most
intimate friendship and
i
totally
was
lied to like 100 lied to the communal
narcissist is the narcissist who gets
their supply by ostensibly doing nice
things for other people they give people
money they do charitable stuff look at
me i'm rescuing an elephant i'm doing
this i'm doing that but they want to be
admired for it and they get their
admiration by doing nice things for
other people and they get angry at
people if they don't feel like they're
getting enough admiration for it so
everybody thinks they're a saint but the
people who maybe work with them or are
in relationships with them say oh my
gosh everyone's telling me i'm so lucky
because they're so helpful but they're
such a mean person there are malignant
narcissists who almost feel psychopathic
they're very exploitative they're very
manipulative they can be
very callous very cold
they almost feel dangerous
they have all the stuff of the grandiose
narcissist but with a much more like
machiavellian like they know how to work
a room they know how to work a system
these are people who often get to the
top of organizations they're not quite
psychopaths which is sort of an entirely
different kind of a thing out there but
they almost have that feel then there
are the self-righteous narcissists who
are super moral and they're like i they
they almost feel really loyal like
they'll they're sort of almost feel
right or die but they're not really
because everything's about how moral and
great they are there's a right way to do
things and there's a wrong way to do
things and they're very contemptuous of
other people they almost feel sort of
snobby and they're very judgy and so
people find them like what is what is
this like this person is not very nice i
hope you're not as stubborn as i am
because it took me 41 years
to
see the lesson
about
toxic behavior that i was attracted to
and toxic behavior that i engaged in in
my own pleasing
and inability to draw a line and like
distance myself or end relationships
that really didn't work gaslighting
isn't something that happens once and
you're all in right it's a grooming
process it happens over time and it
requires you to be in a relationship
that's characterized by trust or some
level of authority or expertise and a
new relationship's an interesting
example of that because if you're
attracted to various elements of the
person how they look and who they are
and you really see that there's a
possibility for a relationship you want
to trust them and when you want to or
you already trust someone and they start
gaslighting you you don't go right to
their gaslighting me
use the first thing most people do when
they're gaslighted is doubt themselves
like maybe they're right maybe i am
being too sensitive or maybe i did read
that situation wrong or maybe i didn't
put the keys there or maybe that didn't
happen or maybe they weren't being
inappropriate with that person and that
happens so it's not happening once or
twice it's happening dozens and then
hundreds of times
when a person's gaslighted they lose a
lot of their power in the situation
because they're spending so much time
saying huh what and you start thinking
like maybe my memory's going maybe i
need to see a doctor maybe i'm the one
with the mental illness maybe i'm the
narcissist you people go there now all
of your time is sort of almost trying to
get back your get your footing back the
gaslighter is controlling you more and
more
really insidious process and then before
you know it
what the gaslighter does it's an
interesting trick
let's say a person finds their voice
it's like okay i've got this figured out
i watched one of dr romney's videos i
read something on gaslighting i got this
and you say something like you know what
like i don't like how you're talking to
me or this i'm not comfortable with this
you know what the gas lighter will say
maybe you're not feeling this
relationship that more i get it like
we've been drifting apart and they start
threatening leaving
they play into a fear that ironically
even though narcissistic people and
gaslighters don't like abandonment they
know it's the ultimate weapon and now
you're into the relationship 6 9 12
months maybe if it's new you say i don't
want this to break up i wanted us to
have a talk and so you're silenced once
again because you feel like if i push
this conversation too much
they're going to feel like i'm pushing
back on the relationship and they're
criticized and so maybe they're going to
want out so maybe i am making too big a
deal out of this and you start
gaslighting yourself
and then before long the person is
almost just living in the gaslighted
universe they may give up on goals
aspirations they may talk to people less
they may give up friendships they may
give up all kinds of things in their
life to live in the universe that the
gaslighter created and so now they're
though to the world it looks like the
two of you are exactly on the same page
you're not on the same page you're
almost like a cult member now you've
been totally brainwashed and you're
going along with the program because
otherwise you lose the relationship
which in my estimation would have been
the best outcome but a lot of people
aren't ready for that that's the process
how can we tell if someone when someone
is trustworthy or not okay so let's talk
about um what i call red flags so these
are cues specifically that
aren't so great that in when we look at
the research
liars typically show them there were
patterns things that people did much
more often on the lying statements and
the true statements so those are our red
flags there are things that our bodies
tend to do in shame deceit guilt and
fear so i'll go through a couple these
are the ones that i want you to kind of
keep in your back pocket of hmm
that was a little odd
why did they do that so the first one is
actually a vocal cue and it's the
question inflection so the question
inflections when we go up at the end of
our sentence so when we're saying
something it sounds like we're asking a
question now think about what the silent
treatment ends up getting you them
though what does it get them you end up
breaking and often say i'm sorry
and they get an apology usually for
something you didn't do wrong
and they hold the power so one could
even argue the silent treatment is sort
of like a satellite of gaslighting but
it's extremely unhealthy it's very
different for a person to say listen i
can feel the steam coming up in me i'm
gonna go take a walk i'm gonna go clear
my head i'm gonna go do what i need to
do but then you come back and talk to
the person the silent treatment is
punishment
and it's a manipulation when someone
takes advantage of you
when someone lies to you you feel wrong
right like i felt so stupid and so
dirty in a weird way even though this
other person had lied to me so i'd just
gone through this friendship breakup and
um
i was watching this in 2005 i was
watching larry king live interviewing
lanza armstrong so
larry king asked him have you ever dove
and lauren's last night has a bold face
lie i've never don't
and then he presses his lips into a hard
line
in a lip purse where he lit his lips
disappeared and he pressed his mouth
together
and i remember watching it going what
was that
so i began to look at the research i
didn't even have the name for it at the
time and i found this is a withholding
cue
the nonverbal research when someone is
trying to keep something in hold back
keep it together they'll lip purse as if
to say don't give yourself away
something you're calling stonewalling
it's similar to the silent treatment but
it's a little bit of a variation on a
theme stonewalling is i'm not going to
talk about this anymore we're not doing
this again or just walking out because
what they've said is i'm not even going
to permit this discourse
it's not you know and so now you're
being told you don't get to bring up
parts of your emotional world a
discomfort about something like that's
all you know no-fly zones so now your
relationship has all these little sort
of marks on it where you can't go there
because we're not doing this we're not
talking about this that's stonewalling
now some people argue that narcissists
stonewall because a topic is about to
bring up their shame so they just say
i'm putting a stop to this and there are
people like john gottman who who talks
about marriage and has done probably
some of the most comprehensive research
on this and to him stonewalling is one
of sort of the you know the death knells
of a relationship if you're engaging in
stonewalling you're sort of at that you
know you're really coming towards the
end how many of us have started dating
or sleeping with somebody
that we knew
we knew
[Music]
we knew we shouldn't have been dating or
sleeping with
and then we keep going back
even though we knew
that this is not a person that we should
be with
and we like
turn into somebody else reckoning with
our and this person is being sent into
your life for a reason because you have
a pattern that you need to break
[Music]
and so when you can identify those three
things kind of when in my life if i felt
this way before what are the
circumstances or people i've been around
what am i doing that i can see
contributes to me getting into these
situations
and what is this trying to teach me
and when you can look at it that way
that's how you unpack awful situations
or confronting situations and you look
for the lesson in them and if you don't
figure out the freaking lessons you're
meant to learn in this lifetime
you're you will just keep i'm embedding
them
that's it that is it
and then danica there are other patterns
like um baiting narcissistic people love
a fight and so you're thinking why do
they say things just to get me worked up
i'm like to get you worked up
they do it's so it's like it's their it
would be like their narcissistic supply
i feel like the drama the chaos the
anger the fear the sadness that comes
out of you is their supply like once
that once there's no more reaction
anymore they aren't getting supply it's
like they just need energy
they not only need but they need energy
but they also need this which is
superiority so let's say you
generally well put together they bait
you and you're like and you take the
bait now you're like ah you're screaming
and yelling and now the narcissist
actually calms down almost instantly
your madness
completely calms them down it's like a
tranquilizer for them and they're like
goodness my isn't somebody getting a
little worked up you need to you look
crazy you need to calm down and that's
gaslighting because now you've been
painted as this thing you're not but you
have literally been baited so it's about
training yourself to not take the bait